he's the son of divorced immigrant
parents when he was nine he sold
newspapers and Christmas cards to
support his family today he's worth
almost three billion dollars he's John
Paul DeJoria and here are his top ten
rules for success well you get there
through one believing in yourself as you
know so well when we started we had $700
made a day to day barely but we believe
what we did was the very very best and
it goes on the premise if you realize
that you're going to run across a lot of
rejection I say this time in and time
out be prepared for the rejection no
matter how bad it is don't let it
overcome you or influence you keep on
going towards what you want to do no
matter what no matter whether your bills
are paid not paid someone says no a
thousand times again go back to be as
enthusiastic on door number 100 as you
were on door number one but believe in
yourself and it's really all about
knowing you have a great service or a
great product that'll put you in the
reorder business so you're never selling
you're trying to get it in someone's
hands whether it's a service or a
product knowing it's so darn good that
they're going to want to order it again
or tell a friend about it to order and
that's the real secret there I've been
homeless twice in my life when you're
down and out it's not an easy thing
first time I was homeless I was 23 years
old second time is when I started John
Paul Mitchell Systems and I was in my
30s and started thinking how bad things
aren't oh my god things are bad how do I
exist in this bad situation I looked at
how do I get out of it one time I had no
money had a car that a broken radiator
had to keep on putting water in it but I
would go around collecting old soda pop
bottles take them in two cents for
little one five cents for a big one get
some money and look for part-time jobs
no matter what they paid I wanted to get
out of it I didn't want to be okay I'm
gonna have to stay this way for a while
how do I survive I look at how I got out
of it and by gosh you can get out of it
America does work you just have to do
something it's a combination one the
product but you could also have the best
product in the world but unless you tell
people about and get them to use it it's
just going to sit there so as a
combination of
a couple of things one that product was
exceptional same with patron tequila's
Paul Mitchell or John Paul pet
exceptional product but then one must do
what those that maybe aren't quite as
successful don't want to do whatever it
takes work seven days a week from early
morning to late at night a lot of
rejection comes your way overcome that
rejection and know that what you have is
so good eventually you'll get through it
eventually getting reorder business
successful people do the things
unsuccessful people don't want to do or
have a very difficult time doing guys
very difficult time and that is keeping
yourself going when nothing's working
when everyone else is saying no no no no
no first thing would be in your category
make it the best you possibly can so
when the end result is the consumer is
tasting it is it something they want to
get again that's number one second thing
is have a story or excitement behind it
which is true we did that with patron
for example we had a tequila tasting
test back in 1989 at Spago's restaurant
and we just won hands down so there was
some validity not just from taste but
from what was going on but in any
product let's say you want to start an
envelope company stay but they can't
come in anything you have to know
yourself that it's the best you can do
and then you have to be willing to tell
enough people until enough people say
yes once they say yes you have to put
your personality into it go by and thank
them make sure it's going well a lot of
people just shoot something out to get
can I get a thousand customers where
they have the first fifty or hundred and
don't pay attention to them you must pay
attention to your first customers unreal
attention it's easier to keep somebody
than this is try and get somebody new
let's do the best we can with what we
have
see we want to live in the now and you
see when you're down and out or having
difficulties your mind is working very
fast not your being your mind is working
very fast and it's working off a lot of
nails from the past so a lot of
experiences from the past and worries of
what may happen the future going through
your mind well if you could eliminate
that by saying okay there's nothing to
do about the past that
Stud yesterday's newspapers can't change
them and who knows for sure was could
have in the future let's be here right
now take what resources we have right
now act upon them and act towards a good
future goal so you are actually going
along the street trading in you know
bottles to get a nickel apiece and in
those days actually was a second time I
was also it's okay
but in those days you got two cents for
a little pop bottle five cents for a big
one in every grocery store and every
liquor store you would just bring them
to and they give you the money and you
know you do a chapter to exist of if
times are lean but alesis nation affords
that opportunity if you know where
you're at well how can I best make it a
survive not oh poor me how do i entrench
myself for long term survival it's how
do I survive right now get myself to the
next step that's the attitude you have
now for starters we know we have a darn
good product but if we take the time
with ourselves and our staff to go in
there and tell them all the ways to use
it and reassure them not only a good
product but here's how you use it to
create a good salon experience or the
consumer when you take it home to keep
your hair the same in between visit you
fill a need in the marketplace
one there's the need of course to buy a
product or another product but the next
one is you must constantly remind them
how to use it properly which makes you a
little different now granted maybe
there's another one use the same way but
nobody told them we're amazing times
when people are using some of our finest
products and didn't know there's other
ways to use it also it's through
education must constantly reinforce the
education and why it's so good I don't
care what you have in life no matter
where you are in your life they'll
always be somebody that needs it more
than you do so whenever you can give as
little as it might be or with us of your
own self I know my 20s in my early 20s
I'd have a lot of money but at
Thanksgiving and at Christmas I've been
Griffith Park in the lines at the feedin
I be feeding people they came on the
line sir I was there at the feed in I
could serve really good I could cut a
turkey SELCO man I got really good at
that I was a good server it made me feel
good because I was part of giving back
as you are part of giving back it opens
you up it opens you the human being
in a huge way you was it your soul the
entity inside of you opens up it's the
most amazing thing it's not about poor
me me me me poor me nama get my look
corner over here for me it's about hey
I'm going to give I mean I have any
money but I'm gonna open that door for
you you need a help at hand I'm going to
be there for you I'm gonna lend a
helping hand your home being opens up
when things like this happen when we
hire people at patron or John Paul
Mitchell Systems
the people we hire do more than one
thing we purposely give someone the
responsibility of several positions
they're paid extremely well we take more
than good care of them but it gives them
the opportunity to be in something that
if times are ever tough you don't have
to eliminate anybody they can migrate
into a variety of things because they're
already doing it now as business thinks
about this and they start hiring people
from beginning with fewer moving parts
we probably have 1/4 the amount of staff
that our competitors have you know per
capita and per you know what we do in
business but we hire where you do more
than one thing in fact I think it's one
of the things that's going to make
America great it made America great in
the past it hasn't been quite as great
as it could be but it will be in the
future where people say of getting one
job to do one thing all the time that
they draw it out because it gets so
boring they do two or three things all
of a sudden they're happy what they're
doing they're excited about it and their
days well long term entrepreneurship is
liking what you do who you do it with
and who you do it for if you're not
having fun then you're only in business
to make some money
I still work I work every single day but
I love what I do so I of fun so it
became a lifestyle when you're working
it becomes work it's not fun when you're
working becomes part of your lifestyle
because you like it it's fun I look
forward to calling on salons I look
forward to walking in some places say
thank you for using Paul Mitchell I look
forward to walking into a cocktail
lounge Wow thank you for having patron
on the menu two people in the hip-hop
industry thank you for singing about
patrolling the country-western Street
thank you for doing this in other words
I like it so much that I appreciate so
much also the people that like it too
it's a lifestyle and it's a good one so
if an entrepreneur can make a lifestyle
that they like with the people they want
to deal with part of their business
it'll be long term and it will prosper
because you are having fun everyone's
that fun thank you so much for watching
I made this video because mole Modern
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the 10
rules you feel most connected to which
help you the most leave it in the
comments below on the joining the
discussion thanks again for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon